so you say that you were very quote
lucky yeah with a car decision knowing
that some of that was luck maybe some of
it was also your planning how can you
improve upon that for the Black Russian
also your third phone well yeah
definitely for a car decision I feel we
got we got lucky you know we happen to
hit at the right time in the right
season and we were able to recover the
funds for the future films the way we
can improve on or the way I am improving
on it is I'm actually making films that
have more content on half the budget so
right off the bat I'm already in a
better position because now much more
efficient in filmmaking than I was with
the first film secondarily we're
targeting a different audience now so
we're targeting California we're
targeting the United States and Europe
so we're targeting Hollywood and that's
where that's what the black question
story is for so are our target
demographic has changed as well so we
made the first film knowing which
audience would respond to a best and
playing on that we found it you know I
did some research and figure like well
what do people what what are independent
you know moviegoers going to want to
watch because we can't compete with the
Avengers you know we're not forget it so
what is somebody likely to you know get
on redbox or what is someone likely to
to to to find interesting and compelling
into views so those are those are some
of the factors that that I had to think
about before actually even getting to
the screenplay of the Black Russian so a
lot of it is about choosing your target
demographic and you I think you tend to
hone those skills as time goes on I
think the third film is going to be you
know the dream is we're going to knock
it out of the out of the park but the
third dream as science fiction elements
and I've always wanted to make a science
fiction film I'm enthralled with blade
runner you know and films like that I
almost felt it wasn't possible but after
finishing the Black Russian in
working in post-production on Black
Russian I figured out how we can do
science fiction you know with lasers and
all the effects on a budget that's
doable for independent film so I think
I'm opening it up to a whole different
demographic now we're opening up to the
comic con crowd and that's a huge crowd
and so that's where um winters dream is
headed you know I see winters dream
headed for that audience and I'm very
very excited about it so it's a learning
process and you learn more about your
demographic the other thing is the other
thing I and I think this is this is for
me this is the most important thing I
make offer decision they're like immerse
to do who are you we don't know you now
in India some people do know me like I
want the airport and I actually wanted a
picture with me like at school all right
so come over here and I try and sell the
Black Russian I go yeah but but I made a
career decision we don't care who are
you you're nobody you know you're some
guy that made a form film big deal now
you want it now you're starting this new
film okay fast forward a year winter is
dream career I'm the guy with the Black
Russian I'm the guy in our crew decision
so that is the other strategy the other
strategy is recognition now because now
there's going to be a certain amount of
people that I remember me from the Black
Russian and the same people that maybe
remember me for my career decisions so
I'm also building my recognition as an
actor so every film that I do in the
future I think I will get to the point I
don't know when but I strongly feel I
will get to the point where i will go to
afm one day and they'll say well who do
you got in the film me okay cool so
let's talk that that's where red do you
feel to that your time management skills
have improved what terms of filmmaking
you said so much of it is just kind of
learning as you go definitely yeah time
management is critical you you you have
to you know when you're filming a low
budget every hour matters of
day so you know first of all managing
just the production itself is hard
because you want to produce that film
within six weeks which is tough because
of actors schedules you know whether
changes and so forth and then post
production is really critical as well
these post-production can go on forever
because of you know editing changes but
at the same time you don't want to lose
sight of of the future so for me I think
time management has has gone a lot
better I think I think the main thing is
working with people who are who are
diligent and who are you know comenzaron
and their level of professionalism so
you really want to surround yourself
with a team of people that are going to
go through this with you through thick
or thin yeah that's that's that's what
it boils down to these in this industry
there's a lot of people that come and go
you know they come onto your project you
know you know making a lot of grandiose
statements like this is my baby you know
I you know this is my dream and then
like two months into it you know you
know where'd they go you know that they
don't want to continue with the cause
but then again every now then you find
that you know that one person or two
who's like you know very interest in the
project is going to you know take it to
completion and you stick with those type
of people and I think they help you with
your time management and I'd like to you
know I want to mention my DP crew for
instance like we I worked with my
director of photography for pickup shots
an awkward decision and I was so
impressed with this guy his work ethic
his name is dilshad bah he does like a
lot of movies in India and I was like
man this guy is like amazing his work
ethic it's just crazy so I called him
for the Black Russian I said I said
they'll shut I'm going to be shooting
this film in northern India in the
mountains it's gonna be crazy the
condition is going to be horrible and do
you want to do it yes or no he was like
I'm all over it because he already
worked with me and he knew how I worked
so he was very enthusiastic so he shot
the Black Russian with me and this guy
was amazing I mean as a DP he was
non-stop in
and he really helped my efficiency and
so now as we're scripting winters dream
I'm in constant communication with him
because he keeps calling me every two
months fees are you done yet are you
telling here what kind of cameras are we
going to use and so forth so you you try
and find the right people and you and
you just stick with them
you